So in this lesson, we will talk about Denial of service attacks and defenses.
We'll talk about; what denial of service
attacks are, various defenses. We'll talk about
how to infer denial of service activity
and we'll talk about how to secure networks
against denial of service attacks. Using, Software Defined
Networking. So what is denial of service? Denial
of service is simply an attack that
attempts to exhaust, various resources. One resource that
a Denial of service attack might exhaust, is
network bandwidth. Another, is TCP connections. For example,
a host, might only have a limited number
of TCP connections that, that it can open,
to various clients. What the Denial of service
attack might attempt to exhaust various server resources.
For example, this victim might be web server
running complicated scripts to render web pages, and
if web server suddenly becomes the target of
a bunch of bogus requests, the server may
spent lot of resources Rendering pages for
requests that are not legitimate. Before 2000,
these denial of service attacks were typically
single source. After 2000, with the rise of
internet worms as we saw in an
earlier lesson, these attacks could become distributed,
effectively being launched from many attackers. Let's
talk about three different types of defenses against
denial of service attacks. First we have
something called ingress filtering. Then we have something
called URPF, or reverse path filtering checks. And
then in the case of an attack on
TCP connection resources, We can use something called TCP syn cookies to defend
against denial of service. Let's suppose that we have a stub autonomous system,
whose IP prefix was 204.69.207.0/24.
Now this is a stub network, that has no
other networks connected to it. And this is the only
IP address space that this network owns. Then, the router
that is immediately upstream of that internet service provider can
simply drop all traffic for which the source IP address
is not in the IP address range of that particular
network. So this is foolproof and it works at the
edges of the internet. Where it's very easy to determine
the IP address range that's owned by a
downstream stub autonomous system. Unfortunately it doesn't work
well in the core, where a particular router
might have a lot of difficulty determining whether packets
from a particular source IP address could be
allowed on a particular incoming interface. So the solution
that operators try to use in the core
is to use the routing tables to determine whether
a packet could feasibly arrive on a particular incoming interface. So
if a router had a routing table that said all packets for ten, that's 0.1.0/24,
should be sent. Via interface one. And all packets destined for 10.0.18.0/24
should be sent via interface two, then URPF says if we see a packet for,
with a particular source IP address on an
incoming interface. That is different than where would
have sent the packet in the reverse direction,
then we should go ahead and drop this
packet. So the benefits of URPF is that
it's automatic, but the drawbacks are that it
requires symmetric routing. And we know from earlier
lessons that routing in the internet is often asymmetric
Therefore in any situation where asymmetric routing is a possibility it
is not possible or reasonable to use URPF. So we've talked about
ingress filtering and URPF checks, and let's now talk about the use
of Syn cookies to defend against TPC based denial of service attacks.